my research what I found is that the
inability or frustration or success
around manifestation always boils down
to your level of deservingness of the
outcome that you're looking for so in
terms of the way this works with
neuroplasticity is that you have to
perform a certain action in the material
world to bring what you want into your
life to perform that action with
confidence you have to have a certain
thought process that tells you if I go
dating I'm going to meet someone really
nice and be able to settle down and have
a family versus if I go dating I'm going
to meet a series of guys who are going
to treat me really badly and it's going
to damage my self-esteem even further
you can see the path that you know those
two people are going to go down and it's
the same for asking for a raise asking
for promotion behind that thought
process will be a set of beliefs that
may be conscious but may be subconscious
as well so you do not even know that
that's what you believe about yourself
that is starting off the thought process
that is either either preventing you or
allowing you with trust and faith you
know to take a healthy risk if you're
able to dig down to that underlying
belief that's when you can do really
powerful work to affect your
manifestation hey it's EV car Michael
and I make these videos because I need
them because being around successful
entrepreneurs who are pushing who are
driving who are doing amazing things
gives me that extra little motivational
inspirational boost in the morning every
day to help me go off and accomplish
great things too and I hope that this
video gives you that inspiration as well
so today let's learn how to manifest
things into your life
enjoy rule number two is just ask with
Ronda burn to manifest something that
you to deliberately manifest you have to
want it but then you can't have any
thoughts of well it's not here yet
because the moment you say it's not here
yet what does law of attraction do it's
not here yet and it's constantly not
here yet yeah so say so say this again
how do we really manifest something we
we put it out there we speak it or we
think it but then we detach from it yeah
yeah and you know here's the thing we so
don't realize our own amazing power that
we can just ask for something and it
will be given to us now here's what
here's what the criticism on Lineas for
the secret or the law of attraction or
anyone talking about manifesting okay
this is what I'll see people and this is
typically people in lack or maybe people
with more of a negative frustration
because they don't have what they want
they will say or these are comments that
I'll see you can't just think something
and expect it to appear without putting
in the hard work without action without
consistency it just the world just
doesn't work like that when you see
comments like that or people say
this how would you respond to someone
saying thinking that or saying that well
I don't um I always kind of feel that
everybody has the right to think what
they want and believe what they want and
I I know it's not the
case um I remember Lester levenson said
something so incredible he was a
wonderful teacher he's not alive anymore
um but he was very simple in the way
that he talked and he he told these
students that if you want something I
could lock you up in a room and padlock
that room and you ask for that and you
know you have it right you know you have
it now and it will come really yeah it
will come and nothing in this world can
stop
it so wow right what are some examples
in your life where you've you've thought
or spoken about something you desired
wanted and it has come effortlessly and
or maybe an example of people that have
written about their success stories is
there anything you can think of
right um where maybe for a long time
they'd struggled and manifesting or
attracting what they wanted but they
started to apply this and really
believed it and that thing came to them
right well when I did a book signing um
and I had I got to talk to all of these
different people and every single person
at that book signing told me about how
their life had completely changed wow
and what was amazing was so somebody
would say that they wanted to have their
working I don't know cleaning a bank or
something and they wanted to have their
own Sound
Studio and that is what they decided to
manifest and they visualized and
visualized and they felted and they
wouldn't allow any thoughts of Doubt to
enter their mind and they are now
running one of the top sound studios in
La wow but not just that they met their
perfect partner they bought their dream
house they have you know two children or
they travel every every single thing
that they
wanted they received and that was what
was so amazing about all of these people
when I was signing books it wasn't just
one thing in their life but these people
were amazing they did gratitude all of
the time or they did affirmations all of
the time and they had a complete change
within themselves you know to
be
kind you know to other people and so
they would think positively they were
aware when negative thoughts came and
they would stop them in their tracks and
so for me I think the biggest
manifestation for me was the
sacret yeah because I W I
was um a mother of two children in
Melbourne
Australia
I had this night where Henny Penny the
sky fell in everything in my life
completely collapsed right and I had a
huge Awakening that night pardon me and
realized
how realized all of this and how
incredible we are and what we can do and
what Mastery we have over the world and
there and then I I looked out at the
world and I'm like no one knows this no
one knows this and so I was determined
that I would find a way to take this to
the world I had no idea what shape or
form form it would take or or but that
night I determined that that is what I
would do and So eventually a whole team
were gathered I had a production company
at that point and everybody might think
oh if you had a production company it's
so easy for you to make a documentary
aha but let me tell you ah there's a
snag I was $2 million in debt really
that production company was $2 million
in debt and my accountant told me you're
going to be broke in 30 days and lose
everything lose
everything and to this day I don't know
how it didn't happen I do know because I
didn't allow that thought I only allowed
the thought of taking this to the world
and nothing else mattered wow but
getting this out into the world rule
number three is feel the fullness with
arar tole Jesus already in in one
sentence one could
say uh told us the
the essence of uh manifesting and how it
works and he said uh whenever you uh
pray for something that you
want uh believe that you already have it
and it will be given to you yes there's
the key now the important thing is he
did not say believe that you will have
it he said believe that you already have
it now this may not be immediately clear
to people how how do I do that uh how do
I believe that I already have it when I
know that I don't have it right right
right how do you get that belief of
having it before knowing feeling tasting
smelling the thing that you want yes so
you
feel uh the
thing it is already a me reality in your
mind how do you feel now that you have
it in your mind how do you how do how
does it feel and this
feeling is really where the power of
manifestation lies but what is that
feeling because that feeling of having
it already feeling this deep sense of
satisfaction is really uh
connecting with a the deeper power
within yourself which is the power where
all all sense of aliveness originates
there it's the deeper sense of aliveness
that comes from Consciousness itself so
no you might believe it might differ
from person to person one person might
think okay what I want is a a big house
with a or on overlooking the ocean or
whatever and then you you feel yourself
you're you're already
there uh experience in that another
person might think well would I want
this uh to have a this great a company
that does good things in this world and
it's and I'm how does that feel but you
might find that the feeling is actually
basically always the same whether mind
is with the house overlooking the O in
know why or the other person says well
this is the company that I'm the head of
the doing great things in this world the
feeling is basically the same feeling
and and the feeling is a feeling of
fullness of Life yes of
completeness that is power so when you
feel this feeling of fullness and then
you associate it with a mental image
that that is a power of manifestation
there but the feeling itself is beyond
the mental image and is beyond whatever
for you are able to manifest in this
world because that is the feeling of the
inherent sense of aliveness it comes
when you can go deeper into yourself and
experience the the presence that you are
and this to to know yourself as the
presence is inherently joyful and
Powerful also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is overcome your
limitations with deepok chobra there's
this feeling of unworthiness like I
would love to have abundance but I don't
really feel worthy of thriving can you
can you talk about that a little bit and
is that really coming from our alignment
with source and soul and I am or is that
more of an ego
thing no there's a difference between
self image and self MH okay self image I
I I use this expression we sacrifice
ourself for our
selfie okay so your selfie becomes your
identity not yourself and what is your
selfie your self image trying to do it
seeks
validation it feels either inferior or
Superior and it is full of fear that's
what these people have who say I don't
deserve it they been conditioned you
know somebody at a long time ago said
you're not beautiful enough or you're
not successful enough or you'll never
make it and or you'll never be such and
such and that creates what is called a
limiting belief in the mind but there
are ways to actually overcome that
limiting belief because you once you
start questioning your
beliefs you say is it really true that I
will never be president of the company
is it is it really true that my husband
or wife doesn't love me is it really
true that I'll never be able to lose
weight whatever your idea of what your
goal is then you can also say how sure
am I if this is true and you know the
more you reflect on this and you say you
say um what is this doing to me why why
is it limiting me and what is the
opposite of this limiting belief now
this is the basics of what people call
cognitive therapy and now there's
something also called awareness-based
cognitive therapy and there's a woman
who wrote a book
called U I forget the book's name but um
she simplified this in a very nice way
um it's basically how do you overcome
limiting beliefs and you do that through
reflective inquiry you do that by
mindfulness meditation
but you also do that by going beyond the
thought process because it's our
thoughts that are limiting us if you go
in meditation you know in the cabala and
all these great amazing mystical
Traditions that's the realm that they
call inol or you know the bud the
Buddhist call it the dharmakaya once
you're at
that understanding that that's what you
just used Ino is um a source is the is
the theere if you want to call it not
the newsphere the newsphere is the mind
the Theos spere is the realm of the Soul
or if you don't like the word Soul
fundamental identity number five is
visualize with Mel Robins not only do I
want you to close your eyes and picture
yourself going back to the dorm room
notice I'm closing my eyes it's because
manifesting is a habit for me and when I
manifest I get in it man I close my eyes
I go into my mind I am literally in my
imagination there and I not only can see
myself doing the work I can feel it you
can feel what it's like to walk into
that dorm you can feel what it's like to
sit down you can feel the heavy backpack
hit the table you can feel yourself
crack open that book you can feel
yourself sitting at that desk in the
desk light and you can can also even
feel what it's like can't you as the Sun
starts to set and it gets darker outside
and the light on your desk starts to get
brighter and take things over you can
just put yourself right there and the
feeling is super important because again
manifesting is Mind Body Spirit we got
to get your nervous system involved
we've got to make you feel like you're
at the scene one of the reasons why
feeling it is so important is because it
magnifies the imagery in your mind and
when your mind rehearses something
here's what's cool about your brain your
brain doesn't know the difference
between you studying for that test or
you doing the work
to start that business or get healthy or
put yourself back out there or heal your
trauma or save the money to get that
house that you want or whatever it is
that you're visualizing your brain
doesn't know the difference between you
visualizing those
things and you actually doing them in
your mind it's the same so it's almost
like a training run for a marathon you
are building a muscle that helps you win
when you take the actions it's so cool
and so you not only want to feel what
it's like to study for that test put
yourself at the scene you also want to
feel a sense of Pride that you're doing
the work and the pride piece is really
important because the pride piece acts
almost like a booster it amplifies the
memory imprint when you like bring this
WOW there I am I'm doing the work I'm
proud of myself I'm staying in I'm
putting in the extra work somebody said
no and I kept on going I I didn't stop
when the first Venture Capital firm said
they wouldn't invest there I am
investing again when you feel this sense
of pride in yourself it supersizes the
the imprint and the rehearsing and so
it's a super important part of the
feeling not only feel the steps feel the
pride that you're doing it this is so
important that I want to give you yet
another example let's say that your
bucket list something on your bucket
list is to run uh a marathon for me it
was on my bucket list when I was a young
mom to run the New York City marathon
now what's interesting is I applied I
got a number and when I won this number
out of a lottery system with the New
York City marathon I was a brand new mom
I was totally out of shape I was not at
all in any kind of of a place to run the
New York City marathon now here's the
thing I used visualization to help me
lower my fear and my excuses because
when I got the number I did not have a
lot of time if I had been a uh person
who was not visualizing I probably would
have said up I don't have enough time to
train I'm not ready I can't do this all
the excuses would have come in but
instead I used visualization now how do
you use visualization for say a marathon
you do not want to visualize crossing
the finish line that is how you
visualize
incorrectly luckily I knew how to
visualize at this moment in my life you
need to visualize yourself going from
zero to preparing to run that so what
does that mean that means you need to
visualize oh there I am it's 5:00 in the
morning oh I don't feel like getting up
but I'm getting up and I'm putting on my
sneakers and it's dark out and I don't
feel like going for a run but there I am
going out the door alone in the cold wow
I am going for I'm I'm pretty proud of
myself because I'm training oh here's
another thing you could visualize I'm on
a training run it's mile 7 and it starts
to rain and I keep going wow I'm wet and
I'm still running I'm proud of myself
because I'm out there training it's mile
11 and my earbuds just lost battery I
don't have any more music I got five
more miles to go I'm out here for almost
another hour and I continue going and I
continue going and I see myself
completing that 16- mile training run
and I allow myself to not only feel what
it feels like to push through that
moment when those earbuds run out of
battery but I Al feel proud of myself
for pushing through that's how you
prepare yourself for the thing that you
need to do because it removes the
obstacles that would stop you from
pushing through and number six the last
one before some very special bonus Clips
is take control with Bob proor when I
was 26 I had a man that sat down with me
and he said why don't you change the way
you're
living it never entered my mind that I
could and looking
back and thinking about I think there's
all kinds of people wandering the planet
there's all kinds of athletes that are
not getting the results they want and
they don't know they can change them
right only one person can change there's
only one person in the whole universe
that can change Bob and that's Bob yeah
there's only one person can change Dave
and that's Dave now we get inspired by
other people we get helped from other
people but we've got to do it oursel and
he gave me thinking Grow Rich and he
said if you do exactly what I tell you
you can give anything you want well I
didn't believe that but he was so
adamant about I believed he believed it
and
so I started to listen to
him and I set a goal I wanted some money
I wanted
$25,000 now this was in 1961 so it was
more money than it is today but I didn't
even know anyone with $25,000 he said
listen write it on a card keep reading
reading the book keep doing what I tell
you so I started to hear people talking
about earning money
and there was one guy said there's good
money cleaning floors he said you should
clean floors well I wasn't proud I'd
clean floors and he said but you should
do it for yourself not for somebody else
so he told me where I could buy a used
floor machine some buckets and mops but
I had to borrow $1,000 well I was at the
point where nobody wanted to touch me
with money and I often say I wouldn't
have lend it to me because I wouldn't
pay it back not that I didn't want to I
just
couldn't but I found a guy and he lent
me the
$1,000 when you when you B me because I
have a question cuz I know you when you
borrowed that thousand cuz you owed
people money already you had explained
that to people you know you were just
finding yourself but did you have a
different feeling about when you
borrowed this thousand that quite
possibly you were actually going to be
able to just to pay this back this time
do you know something if I hadn't had
that feeling I wouldn't have got the
money I got it from a guy I knew his
name Al Kyper he was running and I
didn't know him he had a Trust Company
it was like a bank on Dan Fourth Avenue
in Toronto and I went in I read a book
where it says go to One bank if they
won't give you go to another one well I
ended up sitting in his office and he
said what do you want this money for
son and I told him I was going to build
a cleaning company and it was going to
be big I had a dream
and I had to explain it all to him he
said I think you'll do it I'm going to
lend you the
money faith but I knew when I was doing
this I had a picture I had a dream you
see Y and within a year I was earning
$175,000 a year I had my billing up to
$115,000 a month working for myself less
than 5 years we're working in Toronto
Montreal Boston Cleveland Atlanta and
London England I had my own company off
opening offices all over the
place first you see the need to be a
victim identity also unfortunately is a
form of
ego because any conceptual identity is a
form of ego and even though you seem to
be amply justified in having a victim
identity because of the things that
other humans did to you you yourself are
finding you are finding yourself in a
kind of
prison that created by your
mind so there's no denial of that bad
things happen to you yes now question is
how do you exit this mental
present the first step is perhaps to
see
um that uh unconscious human
beings unconscious human beings in the
grip of their own conditioning their own
ego
they have virtually no free
will when you're
unconscious you are controlled
by the the Mind patterns that are lodged
in your
psyche you have you cannot really speak
of Free Will by somebody with zero
awareness and their entire makeup is uh
conditioning from the past
so the famous sentence phrase used by
Jesus in connection with forgiveness on
the cross he said forgive them for they
know not what they
do now these these two interesting these
points put
together forgive them why forgive them
they know not what they do in other
words if he had spoken these days using
our
terminology he probably would have said
they are completely
unconscious because that's what it means
they know not what they do they are
completely
unconscious uh so when you see nobody
can act beyond their level of
Consciousness then you see that it's
almost like it becomes almost like like
the evil that was perpetrated becomes
almost like a natural pH
phenomenon that is like you've been hit
by lightning or something
or lived in very
unpleasant climatic conditions that that
injured
you near
volcano my dad what had problems with
anger huge outbursts of anger quite
frequently it was living like living
legs to a volcano that could erupt at
any
moment
and he could not help it he was it was
impossible there was no possibility of
being
different and so these
humans are run by unconscious
conditioning usually goes back to their
childhood and what happened
there I know why my father was angry I I
re I realized much later that it all
originated in his childhood the the
reasons why he was so angry and
also for a while also I felt a
resentment towards that and only when I
was able to awaken out of egoic
Consciousness I saw that there there's
nothing that he could have done
differently because there wasn't enough
awareness now when you see that then you
don't
personalize or you don't create an
identity for other humans out of their
unconsciousness because in essence
that's not who they are the recognition
that there first recognition then step
one you recognize that no human can act
beyond their
conditioning in the absence of
awareness if there's awareness they can
transcend their conditioning and then
they begin to become conscious of their
own conditioned mental emotional
dysfunctional mental emotional patterns
yes so they couldn't they can't help it
so that's that's already a useful step
in forgiveness but it you may not yet be
able to arrive at at full
forgiveness because of that another
before I continue with that
does that mean then a question may arise
in your mind does that mean then humans
are not really responsible for what they
do if they unconscious how are they
respons and does that mean then that we
shouldn't punish them for what they do
if they commit a
crime are they not
guilty that's an interesting
question the the
unconsciousness that operates in human
even if you are able to forgive a human
when will come we go more fully into
that in a minute even if you're able to
forgive an human for their
transgressions or whatever they
did uh this does not mean and even
though the human is not responsible for
their
unconsciousness and
yet it is built into the structure of
human
life they still need to suffer the
consequences of their unconsciousness
let's just say that lack is ingrained in
there you got the story you lived on the
streets you lost everything you got
betrayed your business partner took
everything took your wife took you got
the story in the half okay okay you got
to start telling a new story of the
future right you got to believe in that
future more than you have to believe in
the past so how do you do that you only
believe in the past when you feel the
emotions of the past the only time
you're going to believe in the future is
when you feel the emotions in the future
right okay so in order for us to change
a belief or perception about our s and
our
lives we have to make a decision with
such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwire
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond on to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you'll
remember the decision okay so then how
do we downregulate that old belief if
the trauma created an emotional quotient
of six or seven then your decision to
change your belief's got to be a nine
right and you got to come out of your
resting state and that that moment has
to Define you you could say I know
exactly where I was the time and day it
was who I was with when I made my mind
up to change right cuz you created a
long-term memory long-term memories are
created from strong emotions right but
at the amplitude of that emotion is
greater than the Betrayal Boom the body
starts responding to the mind and you're
actually giving your body a taste of the
future emotionally so you brand your
impossible no your body is actually
getting the taste taste of that future
event it's experiencing the future now
exact big explosion on the quantum field
big explosion so the side effect of that
is if you combine that clear intention
with that elevated emotion you're
basically remembering your future and it
looks no different than remembering your
past think neurologically within the
circuits of that memory and feel within
the emotions of that new belief and
watch your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change it when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack or in lack of Separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realize in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so then the
side effect of the beginning of of this
process is a lot of discomfort it is a
lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you you'd rather hold on to your
lack the pain suffering rather tell the
story of that at least it makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel black I'm not going to feel
unworthy I'm not going to feel
separation I'm not going to feel
resentment these are the things that are
keeping my reality the same now it's no
longer about abundance about who you
become mhm so the overcoming process
becomes the becoming process and so many
people come through this work they want
abundance they want healing they want a
new relationship they want a new career
they want the mystical but really they
want wholeness and and they want healing
they want peace they want wholeness cuz
they feel un
well well when you're in lack or you're
in separation you're not whole imagine
feeling so much wholeness that's
impossible to want that's what our
that's what we're working on with people
then you can really enjoy a sunset then
you can really enjoy a meal then you can
really enjoy your friends you can I I I
I talk to people that are very abundant
I mean in the billions abundant and you
know so many of them say we're in misery
our we're in agony because they can't
enjoy life anymore that's what they want
I mean people want abundance to be able
to enjoy life they want to be able to do
whatever they want with whoever they
want as many times as they want wherever
they want that's Freedom right we want
abundance the sponsoring thought is
really they want freedom right or
whatever their sponsoring thought would
be right I used to be the kind of person
that had zero boundaries I mean nada
nothing zilch nothing in fact there were
periods of my life where it was worse
than zero because I was so attached in
romantic relationships that I literally
would become like a human amoeba in my
romantic relationships I mean I was like
literally if it's possible to have
negative boundaries meaning you like
somehow go in a totally different
direction that was me and so if somebody
as insecure and as uh emotionally
attached in relationships and as people
pleasing as me can figure out how to
identify communicate and uphold
boundaries in my life you can learn how
to do this to okay and so that's what
we're going to unpack in this video so I
think a big question because a lot of
people talk about boundaries they know
they need boundaries but they don't have
good boundaries why is that well the
reason why we don't have good boundaries
is because none of us were trained how
to set them I mean I want you to think
about your childhood for a minute your
childhood with your caregivers your
parents your grandparents whoever it is
naturally an imbalance right like when
you come into this world you are born
into a particular family you're born
into a particular culture religion
economic situation a place in the world
a race like a religion and based on
where you were born and to whom you were
born into in terms of the family
structure there were all kinds of rules
that you had to follow and if you did
not follow those rules there were
consequences and so can you imagine if
you as like an 8-year-old started to try
to express boundaries literally like mom
cooks a uh you know a pot pot roast
dinner and you cross your arms you're
like you know
Mom uh this is a boundary cross for me I
have decided that I am no longer eating
meat uh your mom mom would probably go
guess what youngster you not eating
dinner is a boundary Crossing for me
you're not getting up from this table
until you finish what's on your plate
and so saying boundaries when you're
little doesn't really work for the
adults in your life and that's why you
never learned how to do it and by the
way your parents were probably never
taught how to have boundaries either and
so I want to start at the very beginning
okay where do you even begin where do
you even begin when it comes to learning
how to set healthy boundaries okay so
first things first where you're going to
begin is you're going to start to think
about boundaries in a completely new way
okay the number one mistake that we all
make I made it you're making it right
now is when you think about boundaries
you are thinking about other people
first okay you're thinking about
boundaries uh and believing that your
boundaries are rules in a relationship
that define respect and that somehow
your boundaries are going to control or
change someone else's behavior that is
the exact opposite of how you should be
thinking about boundaries okay I didn't
realize this this is why I was lousy at
setting boundaries because I thought
that my boundaries control what other
people do no no no no no so how do I
want you to think about a boundaries
okay boundaries are rules that you
create
about your own behavior and I'm going to
take this a little bit further
now what I'm actually talking about is
I'm going to help you identify
situations people um any kind of uh
experience you might find yourself in
where your boundary defines what you're
going to do in reaction to something
that's going on around you okay because
I think what I'm seeing a lot of
onlineer two things it's this sort of
quick Instagram advice where it's like
you've crossed a boundary you're a toxic
person you're no longer in my life when
the truth is the behavior that we really
need to be policing is our own the
opportunity for growth and the way that
boundaries can support you is in looking
at what you need to change when it comes
to certain people certain situations or
certain choices and habits that you have
okay and we're going to unpack this
don't worry but I really want to kind of
land here because if you start to turn
the focus back on yourself you're going
to have a much easier time with applying
the five rules around boundaries that
I'm about to teach you okay so rule
number one always focus on
yourself what you will and what you
won't allow okay always focus on
yourself what you will and won't allow
do not try to control other people
because you can't okay think about
boundaries as guardrails that you set
for yourself and I'm going to give you a
quick example we all have that relative
that loves to hear them talk about
politics right like it's super annoying
they're constantly going on and on about
politics okay and you want this relative
of yours to stop talking about politics
around you
okay what if I told you that expressing
a boundary with a Rel relative telling
them to stop talking about politics
around you will probably only increase
the likelihood that they're going to and
so the better way to think about
boundaries is not what do I need to say
to Uncle Joe so that Uncle Joe does not
talk about politics around me that's not
how you do this you don't go Uncle Joe
you're crossing a line with me you're
crossing a boundary I need you to stop
talking about politics let's just role
playay that for a minute how do you
think that that's going to work that
ain't going to work very well is it no
CU then Uncle Joe's going to flare up
and then you're going to flare up and
now instead of having a boundary that
you held you've got a gigantic mess
that's been made instead you got to
think about that boundary with you
okay what are you going to do and there
are two examples of this you could
decide that if that relative starts
sounding off about
politics that is a boundary for you and
you will remove yourself from the room
that's an example of how you can set a
boundary another example is you could
say something to Uncle Joe and you could
say hey Uncle Joe I love you and I'd
love to have you over for dinner but if
you plan on talking about politics when
we're together we're not going to have
dinner you have defined what you will
tolerate or not you didn't say do not
talk about politics you said I love you
if we're going to have dinner together
I'd love to have you over for dinner but
not if we're talking politics you've
given Uncle Joe the option to talk
politics or not you've just made it
clear where you stand which is we're not
having dinner together if you opt to do
that do you see how that's about your
behavior you've made it clear what
you're going to do but Uncle Joe now has
a choice
to either respect the boundary or not
certain actions take place you do things
you
know they're
not the optimal things to do but you
can't help it it's
something acts through you um there
there seems to be some power there that
makes you do things that you know know
are not right or not good for you and
and yet you can't stop it that seems to
be the case
um and that of course
um is often the case with people who are
with you it might be many different
different areas of your life but uh
um this is also the case with addictions
for example people who are addicted to a
certain substance or who are addicted to
eating too much or drinking um there's
something that overpowers them in you
that seems to
obscure the
awareness or the awareness is pushed to
to the side and this thing this this
powerful thing does it
anyway and again my answer is a little
bit similar to um
what I say to the first questioner
tonight
the the power of
presence needs to grow in you so
that it is strong enough not to is not
willpower because willpower is not the
best way of dealing with these things
but it's what I'm talking about could
sometimes be confused with willpower but
willpower includes the um application of
a force to hold something down let's say
um if your addiction is to um have a to
indulge in intoxicating beverages in
other words booze is the British word uh
then uh and you can feel it it's it
comes on there it comes you know the
bottles are there there they are and you
feel you have to go there and you have
to reach out and you have to pour
yourself a drink now when you're not
aware at all you don't even know what
you're doing you're so unconscious that
you you're already holding the drink and
you're drinking then you at that point
you you even know that you're drinking
uh the same with food I've spoken to
people who have had addictions to food
they often say they wake up when they
already they've already eaten in the
middle of the night they've already
unconsciously gone to the fridge taken
out the chocolate cake and then they're
already halfway through the chocolate
cake when suddenly like what am I
doing but so awareness comes in at a
very late point will power would be to
hold an urge down let's say I go they
have the pull or even what the example
you gave you want to turn on the TV and
you know it's not right because I I'm
not here for that and he actually told
us not to do
it and I but I can't help it I have to
go I can't I can't no willpower you
would you would say I'm going to hold
this down I'm not going to do
it and I you can feel the urge but you
holding it
down um when you hold things
down often after a while the an
explosion happens it's like a boiling
cattle can't hold it for that long and
then you have some kind of
rationalization in your mind why it's
you'll do it anyway the mind will give
you a reason I think there are many
modalities that work for trauma what
I've discovered is that Insight never
really changes Behavior you can see that
your father was overbearing or was an
alcoholic or you could see all these
different things you know like you could
come up with the Insight all these
different things the problem that I see
with people is then they tend to excuse
their
change by saying oh I had a rough
childhood that's why I am the way I am
they're excusing their pre present
position so and again trauma is a
difficult thing but for
me the person who's living by the
identity in their life that they were
traumatized as a child or whatever it is
or they've had a trauma in their life
I'm not saying forget the trauma and
create another emotion I'm saying that
the person who's willing to go through
the
emotion and keep working on lowering the
volume to it the the we have had so many
people in this work with brutal pasts
really really difficult pasts do the
work and finally they reach that point
where they just break free from the
emotion they look back and I have
interviewed enough of them it's the same
thing they look back at their entire
past and they don't want to change one
thing in their past cuz it brought them
to this elegant moment where they're
liberated they see their betrayers they
see their abusers they have nothing but
love for them now the side effect of
that and many times they'll say it was
like my heart blew wide open they had to
pass through the valley of the shadow of
Darkness to get there they just thought
I I don't know if I can go any further
and they went one more
time and the body literally was
liberated from the past right cu the
trauma is not just in the brain the
trauma stored emotionally in the body so
you want to take the body out of the
past out of the known what do you think
the body is going to say if it's been
conditioned to be the mind the unknown
is a scary place you step out into the
unknown you're going to be unprepared
for that trauma you don't know how it's
going to happen and so the person keeps
clinging to the known and but when the
person finally overcomes the emotion the
body literally is freed from the chains
of the past the side effect of that is
seeing the past from a greater level of
Consciousness lo and
behold there goes the Suicidal
Tendencies there goes the dysfunction
there goes the irritable bowel syndrome
that was because the body was still
living in that past event by living by
the same emotion so the research on
memory is kind of fascinating and I just
I've studied it enough and and
and the way we recount the past is not
the way it happened even if you
absolutely think you remember it being
that way so we don't have the same brain
as we did when we were 8 years old or 12
years old or 20 years old we have a
different brain we have a completely
different brain so the fabrication of
the story for many people they embellish
the story and make it seem even worse
than what it was but you're really what
you're saying is I changed in those
moments and from a biological standpoint
I haven't been able to change since so
let me tell you why it's been so hard
for me to change and the story becomes
dramatized or
embellished the person Works them up
fire themselves into this emotional
froth and then fires and wires the same
circuits in the brain and they're
actually reaffirming their limitation
now there's nothing wrong with that I
think we're just taking too long right
so 50% of that story isn't even the
truth it means in a sense we're reliving
a miserable life that we never even had
and we don't want but but the but the
the unknown people would rather cling to
their
suffering this is not a judgment we all
do this we'd rather stay in the known
than take a chance in the unknown
because those emotions of survival are
saying what run from the unknown the
unknown is a scary place so now the
unknown you got to come up against that
moment where you're going to actually
leave that behind and step into the
unknown this is not a intellectual
process this is this is David and
Goliath there's a battle going on where
the body keeps wanting to go back to its
familiar State cuz it's subconsciously
been conditioned to be the Mind stay in
the known usually happiness exists as
part of the play of opposites you
experience the happiness because
something makes you happy and then that
thing that made you happy either leaves
you or the very thing that made you
happy suddenly makes you
unhappy marriage for
[Music]
example or a
relationship before you start living
together you're happy when you start
living together you were
unhappy so what is if it's not happy
what are we talking about
the there's
a if
you let go of thinking and remain as the
awareness then there is in that that
awareness eminates a certain peace
alive
peace joy peace a
peaceful joyful sense of
aliveness inner peace maybe a better
word than happiness but one would have
to add to it it's an alive peace it's
not the Peace of uh having deadened
yourself to
emotions or anything like that it's an
alive intensely alive piece you can
sense it even if it's only just a
glimpse right
now surrender
thought and of
course right now if you're not thinking
about the problems of your alive there
are no problems in this moment there's
only a sense of beingness or
liveness and that is the connectedness
with
being and so you transcend the Opposites
between happiness and unhappiness to
overcome the
body takes a will that's greater than
the program to to no longer get up and
run through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say wait wait
wait wait wait a second here we're not
going anywhere until I get clear on who
I want to be today and every time you
execute that will that's greater than
the program people say oh I'm I can't
meditate actually you're doing it right
actually that's why it's hard because
doing it you're actually that is the
process right there there's no such
thing as a bad meditation what you're
doing is actually exactly what you need
to do and every time you do that you
become conscious that you go unconscious
that's how you actually develop the
skill of Consciousness it's not being
conscious it's catching yourself when
you go unconscious and people if they
can see thinking is the unconscious
essentially conscious is connecting to
everything which is in the space of
nothingness really but there's a journey
to get there and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that as a
victory like oh you start getting
aroused you start getting frustrated you
think I can't do this and you go oh no
no no no no no no we're not going to
quit here that would be me getting up as
the same person I'm curious what's on
the other side of this frustration you
settle your body back down into the
present moment you unfold back into that
Eternal space I'm telling you every time
you do that it's a victory you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind then it actually
turns out that the body starts
liberating energy it starts re
liberating energy but like an unbridled
stallion it goes oh really you think
that's all you think that's all you have
watch this and then it get starts
bringing up memories of the past and all
of that just to feel an emotion and if
you're aware that it's doing that and
you settle it down you're you're taming
the animal you're teaching it you're
you're teaching it how to change its
state right and guaranteed if you keep
doing that you walk out in your life I
guarantee you'll be less responsive and
reactionary to everyone and everything
so in 7 days we see that not only there
dramatic biological changes to suggest
that the person different
environment but it it goes for the
majority of people that immerse
themselves and going all in and what
does that mean a different environment
they're in a ballroom they're in a
ballroom I've been to thousands of
ballrooms there's nothing really
exciting in a ballroom what's exciting
in a ballroom they all look the same but
the data suggests that they're in a
whole new environment where where is
that where is that taking place it's
taking place from within the person
closed eyed internal world is
everything open
fulfillment is when you're
satisfied because you are fully
developing your deepest
desires and your character fulfillments
very different than happiness
everybody
happiness comes and goes happiness is
fleeting happiness is like the
waves in an ocean or the waves on Lake
Michigan the Great Lakes here in the
United States which is where I grew up
on Lake Michigan the waves they come and
they go right that's happiness it comes
and it goes it rolls in and out of your
life and oftentimes it feels like it's
out of your
control
fulfillment is the ocean or the Great
Lakes
itself fulfillment is something way
deeper and
fulfillment is about
integrity and
meaning and the fact that when you have
integrity and meaning in your life you
are
fulfilled you are
satisfied because you are fulfilling and
fully
developing your deepest
desires and your
character and this is important and I'm
going to really Hammer these words
around meaning and more importantly
Integrity if I had to pick one word that
was important when it comes to you
deepening your level of fulfillment with
your whole
life the word is integrity now this was
brand new to me you know I always
thought about fulfillment like oh find
your joy find your passion find your
purpose like then you'll be fulfilled do
things that you love you'll be fulfilled
it actually has more to do with
Integrity which is really cool and you
know when I explain why Integrity is so
important it's also going to
illuminate all the places in your life
where you're not fulfilled because I
guarantee you the places in your life
where you're missing fulfillment are
also lacking personal
Integrity you're not
operating consistently with what you
care about you're not operating with
Integrity in terms of your values you're
not spending your time your energy and
your resources on what truly aligns with
you from an Integrity standpoint and so
that's why we're going to continue to
hammer this word inte
okay and that's great because when you
start to think about cultivating
personal integrity and how that
translates to more fulfillment in your
life it's going to make that fulfillment
something that you can cont control it's
going to make it deeply personal it's
going to make it something that you can
move the needle on it puts the locus of
control within your reach let me talk
about the two mistakes that everybody
makes okay when it comes to fulfillment
and this is why fulfillment in some
areas of your life are Out Of Reach
right now number one the number one
mistake that we make if you're
struggling with fulfillment in any area
of your life is that you're not living
according to your own
values you know I think we've all gone
through those periods of Our Lives where
we are drinking too much or we're
spending too much money or we're hanging
out with the wrong people or we're
making unhealthy choices and you know
deep down inside that this is not what
you want to be doing it's not what you
should be doing but because you are not
living based on your own values you
don't respect yourself there's no way
you are going to live a fulfilled life
if at the base level you don't respect
the choices that you're making so can
you identify an area of your life right
now either in the chat or in the journal
uh function in the app an area of your
life where you are not living according
to your own values I see Health coming
up for people I'm sure if you think
about how you're spending your money or
whether or not you're saving money
you're not aligned with your values
maybe you're doing work I see
productivity I see exercise so if you're
not living according to your own values
this is one reason why you're not going
to be fulfilled in your life the second
thing is that you spend your time and
your resources on things that actually
don't matter to
you you're spending your time and your
resources on things that don't matter to
you at the deepest level these are the
two big mistakes that we all make and
the good news here is that these are
mistakes that you can easily identify
that you can address and when you do you
take control back and you will amp up
the level of fulfillment that you feel
I'm going to say this
again fulfillment is not the same thing
as happiness
fulfillment is meaning and
integrity and that's why habit number
one and building a foundation is about
values because you will only find
fulfillment true lasting deep
fulfillment everybody if you are
following your values like a compass not
your mood you got to follow your values
and let that be your compass
that's how you build the proper
foundation and so what does that mean
what does that mean everybody well it
means you got to figure out what matters
to you okay and then you must develop
the simple
discipline to spend your time and energy
on things people experiences that align
with what matters to
you living with integrity to what
matters to you is the secret of
fulfillment and I think you know i' I've
alluded to this earlier but you know I
can think about times in my life when
either what I was doing for work or what
I was doing with my free time did not
align with my values the sense of being
an outsider is also something that I
have
had throughout my life and uh the sense
of not belonging
here
uh watching my
parents being
engaged in
continuous
conflict not because they were bad
people they were they did what they did
and they loved me as best they could and
they did what they
did and as a reflection of their state
of consciousness at that time which was
a normal State of Consciousness egoic
State of
Consciousness but I sometimes felt how
did I get
here somehow didn't there must have been
a
mistake
um it's often
Outsiders uh on it being feeling an
outsider on the one hand is seems a
terrible limitation that you can't
participate as much on the other hand
it's a great opportunity
because some of the uh most creative
people uh in the world have have been
Outsiders they did not fit
in uh Misfits is the English word
Misfits
um now that's the friendships I had when
I was a
child and that's another interesting
thing I had
a friend one of my friends was had was
severely
physically
disabled and nobody else wanted to be
friends with him because of that and he
was probably my closest
friend and the other one was so weird
that nobody wanted to talk to
him uh but he became my friend so they
were Outsiders
too and
uh but the interesting fact here as you
know I couldn't believe it when they
told me that there are people here from
70 countries it seems almost
unbelievable but that's true I saw the
list 70
countries and you may find I'm sure you
will
find quite
often uh you you you can feel a bond or
you you have more in
common with many of the people who are
here than you have with your own people
in your own country at home who are not
going through any Spiritual Awakening
who are still totally conditioned 100%
conditioned by their culture so you feel
a connectedness here with other humans
that transcends culture and conditioning
and all the silly political stuff it
transcends that and this is a wonderful
thing so to some
extent you can now connect with people
even if you don't always see them
physically you might live I don't know
whether you live in a big city or a
small
village a small City small City small
City yeah yeah what city uh inbrook in
Austria oh yes yeah nice very
nice uh I don't know how many people in
insbrook are
120,000 and how many of those are
Awakening we don't
know
we don't know of course but this helps I
believe being here and feeling you are
not
alone you are
connected so this should be a help for
the rest you just have to accept that
this is how it is and no matter how hard
you try to fit in on the normal level
you probably won't nor do you have to so
I know this there are many people here
who feel that and be happy with it but
don't make it into some kind of
superiority because the ego can always
creep
in before you know it there's always a
back door and then the ego is back in so
you can you could go from feeling bad
about being an outsider to suddenly
feeling okay I'm an outsider because I'm
superior and then so have to be careful
don't go that there so um that's just
how it is if you you probably would not
be here if you had not been an out felt
like an outsider for many years so it
worked because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
to master your thinking to shape reality
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there how can people
begin to attract the life that they want
to bring abundance into your life you
have to be cultivating an abundant
mindset and so a really easy way to
start is to list the things that you're
grateful